everything has a rhythm whether you're
fighting whether you're walking whether
you're typing on a computer you will
naturally fall into a rhythm it takes
far more conscious effort not to adopt a
rhythm than it does to adopt a rhythm
our ability to observe rhythms to create
beats is highly important then to our
psychological function and our
performance in athletics martial arts
and more so in parkour we need rhythm
because when we're running towards a
wall or a ledge we need to fall into the
cadence and adopt a specific rhythm in
order to make sure that our footing is
correct once you're at that right point
otherwise we jump too early or too late
or stumble over ourselves and faceplant
in martial arts or boxing you need to
adopt a rhythm and you need to adapt to
the opponent's rhythm and then find
breaks in that pattern in order to
sucker punch them and catch them
unawares it's an incredibly valuable
technique when we're typing when we're
running we fall into a natural cadence
and this rhythm helps us to perform our
very best and when predicting the
movements of things in the real world
around us we need to use rhythm in order
to predict where they'll be at a given
time where you're watching something fly
through the air it has a kind of rhythm
it's the same mechanisms that you're
using in your brain you ability to
predict movement over time and to
anticipate those patterns and in case
you think I'm just blowing smoke there
are studies demonstrating that rhythm
training can improve the performance of
tennis players versus those who've
engaged in no such timing again because
it helps them presumably to predict the
movement of the ball and to fall into a
rhythm with their opponent that they can
then exploit later on a particularly
obvious example of beat and rhythm being
useful in terms of performance is in
computer games you've ever played the
game where there's a bouncing object you
have to run through it at the right time
or a laser that goes on and off this
demonstrates how being able to predict a
pattern go help you to avoid a hazard
and lots of computer games are built
around this concept one of my original
examples of why we need rhythm was that
in real life you might find yourself
faced with a stalactite that's dropping
in a cave a certain rhythm you have to
dive under it then I realized that
literally will never happen to anyone so
the ability to predict and sense rhythm
really does have the multiple benefit
whether you're looking at sports
six martial arts parkour gymnastics or
even something like long-distance
running or typing long essays we're
falling to a rhythm helps you to get
into a kind of groove and more easily
enter a flow state and is there
something we don't all have to the same
degree we've already seen that you can
train to improve your rhythm and some
people are actually unable to sense
rhythm at all I haven't mate who is weak
to death and this means he can't hear
and adapt to a beat and he looks like a
complete tosser on the dance floor this
might actually be by the way why we find
people who can dance well attractive
because an ability to sense of rhythm is
a trait that has a survival value okay
so where in the brain is rhythm located
but on the one hand you've got your
auditory cortex which of course handles
auditory information so it makes sense
that this would be useful for sensing a
rhythm and indeed damage to this area
will impair your ability to sense peace
however beats and rhythms aren't only
auditory they can also be visual as
we've seen and in fact my friends whose
be deaf interestingly says that he's
much better at keeping time when he sees
something visual so he can dance by
watching other people dance and
mimicking them like a gorilla
so like I've said it also seems that an
ability to sense rhythms and beats is
connected to our ability to sense the
passage of time in general and this
might be further insight into why it's
just so valuable and the areas of the
brain that are responsible it seems for
sensing the passage of time are the
cerebellum the cerebral cortex and the
basal ganglia and again damage to these
parts of the brain can impair our
ability not only to sense rhythms but to
sense the passage of time in general fun
fact I used to be able to perfectly cook
an egg without using a timer I no longer
have that ability my eggs come out bad
what's really interesting to me is the
fact that our ability to sense rhythm
and the passage of time seems to be
related closely to ability to visualize
in general and this is in keeping with
some of the things I've talked about
recently on this channel so when we
predict how long the movements going to
take or when we try to engage in some
kind of physical rhythm like a dance we
actually use the motor cortex or the
premotor cortex to estimate how long
that's going to take and how long the
gaps in between those movements are but
when we estimate how long something
visuals gonna take when we try and
predict a flashing light for instance
that actually uses the
cortex so it seems that we're literally
simulating the action in our brain and
how accurate that simulation is
determines just how accurate our
prediction of that rhythm or that beats
gonna be so it might be that improving
your beat could have crossover effects
and improve your general visualization
your general embodied cognition and your
whole ability to think it's more
complicated than that we don't really
understand how it all works because in
one study rats had their entire cortices
removed and they still had some
lingering remnants of time perceptions
remaining so since this is a really
innate ability that might be very
unconscious to a certain extent which is
why we fall into a rhythm when we walk
or when we're breathing and that means
that some of these other processes are
kind of layered on top of that so you
might have multiple levels of beat
perception but once we don't know
entirely how our perception of beats and
rhythms work what we do know is that
it's important for our performance and
our athletics and fighting so we want to
try and improve it as much as possible
so how would we go about doing that well
in the study I talked about earlier
where tennis players were improving
their rhythm using vision training they
actually would hit the ball or perform a
certain movement to the tick of a
maximum so that's something you can very
easily take part in on your own just set
up some kind of repetitive beat a
metronome or perhaps something on the
computer and then time your movements in
Concord with that you can also find
videos online that let you try and
predict your sense of rhythm this is
designed specifically for training and
improving that sense of rhythm he's
often involved a flashing light or a
bouncing
object and your job is to try and
remember that rhythm adapt to it and
then the visual stimuli or the auditory
stimuli will disappear and you then need
to continue the rhythm and then when it
reappears you can see how close you were
if you try it a few times you'll find
that you gradually improve I'll put a
link to that down in the description
below you can find it in the article
that accompanies this video on the biome
ear calm and like I was saying earlier
any computer game that challenges your
rhythm will also help to improve your
innate ability to predict beats while
I've been playing recently oh that's
really cool
it's called thumper and this describes
itself as a rhythm violence game when
you play it you'll see what I mean it's
really intense and it's awesome in
virtual reality
likewise is also a rhythmic element in
another game you're playing Whateley and
that's read in
which I just love you can also improve
your rhythm from games like Guitar Hero
of course or any of those just dance
games another really good one actually
is the Batman Arkham series where the
combat is based very much around with
them and here you're hitting your
Perry's and your combos after certain
time based on prompt on the screen and
it's brilliant for improving your
ability to quickly react based on a
rhythm and a timing and what better way
to train your rhythm and timing than
playing a game about Batman but finally
one of the very best ways you can
improve your sense of rhythm is by
playing an instrument playing
instruments been shown to be great for
all kinds of cognitive faculties it's
great to have brain plasticity your
creativity and yes it's also very good
for your rhythm and your timing the
drums will be particularly good but any
instrument will boost your ability to
sense rhythms to predict patterns and to
move with perfect timing so hopefully
this video useful interesting guys if
you did please consider leaving a like
and showing it around it really helps me
out the thing you can do for me that
helps the most is to share this on
places like reddit any forms you take
part in that gives me a massive boost
and I thank you in advance if you can do
that let me know in the comments down
below what you think whether this is the
kind of training you're going to be
adopting into your own routine and what
kind of stuff you'd like to see from me
in the future I've got a whole bunch of
stuff coming up topics on productivity
new trade picks brain training fitness
martial arts you name it all the usual
stuff so if that sounds good then
subscribe and I'll see you next time
thanks so much for watching and bye for
now